In this and our previous lessons,
we developed a set of ideas and
definitions.
To set the stage for understanding what
we can, and cannot solve on a computer.
We've seen the Turing machine,
an amazingly simple model that can only
move a tape back and forth,
while reading and writing on that tape.
Yet we see that this model capture the
full power of computers now and forever.
You see now how to consider Turing
machine programs as data themselves.
And create a universal Turing machine
that can simulate those programs.
At the end of this lesson, we saw some
languages defined using program as data,
that don't seem to be easily decidable.
In the next lecture,
we will show how to prove many languages
cannot be solved by a Turing machine.
Including the most famous one,
the halting problem.